Lucy was only 15 when a relative hired
her as their domestic worker her parents
thought she would be safe with them she
wasn't
FinCEN Antartica you know she knew to
talk when you don't continue hey it's a
big animal and in a non Kananga lucky
but you Maggie doing lemons in a beacon
to Sarah lucky I mean yeah eople o'clock
good now focus upon the lamina Misawa
Korea Papa tying a tie in the lava there
gonna be some boom handle salmon and a
pillar coordinate land element I
admission are you doing this expand
domestic work is a default job for many
Filipinos but it can also be dangerous
the President of the Philippines even
weighed in recently on the abuse of
domestic help in what many saw as a
shocking confession on what he did
decades ago
I touch when Philippine president
Rodrigo de character recently confessed
to molesting his domestic worker as a
teen he revealed a dirty little secret
many domestic workers in the Philippines
are sexually assaulted by their
employers
novalee the police walk runs a union for
domestic workers and was also shocked by
the president admission so as a parent
agree sad and degrading just because
workers have low status does it mean
they can be treated this way goo rocks I
mean bucket ow
novalee the police Hawk says that while
rape is the worst that can happen
domestic workers face sexual harassment
on a near daily basis
police ox male employer once groped her
while she was changing a light bulb she
did not complain thinking his wife would
not believe her
Claire Padilla is a lawyer who has been
at the forefront of women's rights for
over a decade sexual abuse among
domestic workers here in the Philippines
is very prevalent unfortunately we do
not have statistics on that and this is
probably because of the silence of the
victims silence of the families because
it happens in their families there is a
lot to protect the estimated 1.9 million
domestic workers in the Philippines but
activists say it's flawed domestic
workers can be as young as 15 an age
when people are too young to know their
rights and fight back against abuse and
violence like the kind Lucy experienced
over 20 years ago hello Seattle again at
Sara Nambu a Dinoco negara namah so
Cannella Nicole
ksama Makita Yamata Lucy endured a
lifetime of
shame and suffering she hopes that were
the president's admission more domestic
workers will break the silence on their
past so that other women don't have to
suffer and joining us now from Manila is
Claire padilha she's a women's rights
lawyer featured in that report
Claire good to see you now we just heard
in that report President Duterte
essentially confessing to sexual
harassment what is the message that is
sent out when a president confesses
essentially to a crime but then gets
away with it
yes well that's a huge problem because
he actually midnight or can be called
sexual harassment it can be called
sexual assault it can be considered even
rape here in the Philippines
unfortunately he was in fact bragging
about it so I mean that's why we don't
work on gender-based violence
I've been a lawyer working on rape cases
for more than 25 years so when I tell
you that he is not helping our work he
in fact encourages bad behavior and even
sexual assault and that should not be
happening and in the case of the
president I would say that in other
countries there are there would have
been a fall for such act of a president
to resign
however here in the Philippines some of
the problem is that some of the audience
even laugh at his demeanor and his
scoring so I would say that really have
a long way to go in terms of
understanding gender-based violence but
having compassion having compassion for
the victim survivor and and actually
effectively prosecuting their cases you
speak about prosecuting rape you speak
about prosecuting rape cases and taking
action against sexual harassment there
is a law against sexual harassment and
also laws that protect domestic workers
in the Philippines are these not working
the problem in the past and include now
is that even while we work on the
amendment of the anti lift law and in
the amendment work in the passage of the
anti-sexual harassment act we even have
lost with leg pain domestic workers but
there's a huge success that happens
whether it's with community level
officers whether it's the prosecutors
whether it's the police
I mean even a lot of judges and justices
so we have this missiles by the
prosecuting by investigators
we have quick votes by judges and
justices regardless of whether they are
women and women women's rights law
except Padilla's speaking to us from
Manila thank you very much for your time
you